RETALIATION, THERE HAS BEEN NO
INDEPENDENT COOPERATION OF THAT
REPORT.
AT LEAST TWO PEOPLE ARE DEAD AS
WILDFIRES IN THE U.S. RAGE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE OUTBREAK COMES DESPITE
EXTRAORDINARY MEASURES BY POWER
COMPANIES TO MINIMIZE THE RISK
THERE.
NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT WILLIAM
LA JEUNESSE IS LIVE TONIGHT IN
PORTER RANCH NEIGHBORHOOD OF
LOS ANGELES.
GOOD EVENING, WILLIAM.
>> THE FIRE BEGAN 9:00 LAST
NIGHT WHEN THE SANTA ANA WINDS
JUMP OVER THE RIDGE, RACED INTO
THE L.A. BASIN, DEVASTATED THIS
COMMUNITY WHILE MANY SLEPT.
>> I COULD SEE THE FLAMES COMING
OVER THAT RIDGE.
I SAY, WE GOT TO GO.
>> EVERYTHING IS FIRE UP THERE.
THE HOUSE IS, EVERYTHING IS ON
FIRE.
IT'S BAD.
>> THE FIRE EXPLODING AS WINDS
SWEEP THROUGH THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY.
>> SHORTLY BEFORE SUNRISE AT
PORTER RANCH.
THIS FIRE IS 0% CONTAINED.
>> NOBODY KNOWS WHAT THESE WINS.
WE ARE HOPING FOR THE BEST.
>> 100,000 EVACUATED HERE AND
TWO FATALITIES, A MAN IN HIS
50s SUFFERED A HEART ATTACK
TRYING TO PROTECT HIS HOME.
ANOTHER DIED OF THIS FIRE, EAST
OF LOS ANGELES, THAT DESTROYED A
MOBILE HOME PARK.
>> THIS IS GOING TO TAKE A FEW
DAYS.
>> WITH STRONG SUSTAINED WINDS
AND HUMIDITY UNDER 10% FROM THE
FIREFIGHTERS ARE ON DEFENSE
PROTECTING HOMES AND DROPPING
RETARDANT, HOPING TO SLOW THE
FIRE TO SOME 800 ACRES AN HOUR.
>> IT'S A ROUGH ESTIMATE RIGHT
NOW, BUT WE ARE LOOKING AT A
NUMBER OF AT LEAST 25 HOMES HAVE
BEEN DAMAGED.
>> SEVERAL HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS MOSTLY IN THE
NORTHERN PART OF THE STATE
REMAINED WITHOUT ELECTRICITY AS
POWER COMPANIES HAVE VOLUNTARILY
PULLED THE PLUG FEARING
LIABILITY WITH DOWNED POWER
LINES.
>> WE ARE SEEING THE SCALE AND
SCOPE OF SOMETHING THAT NO STATE
IN THE 21ST CENTURY SHOULD
EXPERIENCE.
WHAT'S HAPPENED IS UNACCEPTABLE.
>> IN ADDITION TO CRITICISM FROM
GOVERNOR NEWSOM, A FAMILY OF A
67-YEAR-OLD MAN IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS BLAMING THE
UTILITY WHEN HIS OXYGEN MACHINE
STOPS 12 MINUTES AFTER THE